la la la bonté prémont gran via je suis
prêt de chez près chaque habitant de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star grâce à notre concours de chant
vous allez être ébouriffés par le pays
qui sait comment ça va très bien merci
fo
si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars vous allez
devoir travailler plus dur que vous ne
l'avez jamais fait toute votre vie
c'était très mauvais ou et joly eelv est
pas là oui c'était une répétition
papa je veux pas faire partie de son
gang ce que je veux c'est être chanteur
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toile de fond c'est élise et
hélitreuiller du toit il contiendra que
me y arriver oui ou non je suis là
qu'est ce qui se passe ici il faut
jamais y c'est la peur nous empêcher de
faire ce qu'on aime et sait ce qu'il
advient quand on a touché le fond c'est
qu'il ne reste plus qu'une issue on doit
c'est mon fiston
elle est hyper ni celle là ouais non
c'est clair je peux pas bouger
allez centre
je suis désolé
c
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas entendre
répéter chaque fois c'est moi ils m'ont
carrément accusé d'être égocentrique
je n'aime pas ce que ça veut dire
les faveurs de la cote et semaine à
toutes ses facettes
n'a qu'une mission tu devais faire le
guet désolé papa mon théâtre est dans
une mauvaise passe depuis un moment déjà
et donc la section du ferme non je monte
un spectacle devine quoi roulement de
tambour un grand concours de chant
imagine ton voisin le gérant du
supermarché se saouler qui passent là de
vrais talents venus de la vraie vie
norman tu deviens leur dire que j'ai une
très jolie voix et son chéri et tu
chantais bien fou au fait le lavabo de
la salle de bains est encore boucher je
suis ici pour gagner ce prix je l'aurais
chaque habitant de cette ville a une
chance de devenir une star dans monte à
ça va oui ça va très bien merci est fou
ils n'ont rien donné
ouah
ses spectacles il ne sauvera pas ton
théâtre il serait peut-être temps de
passer à autre chose
je vous en prie vous savez ce que ça
représente pour nous tu ne peux pas
juste chanter les paroles tu dois
montrer le fou qui te l'effort le feu ça
fait longtemps qu'il est sain que jamais
croire ce que j'ai fait aujourd'hui
bah je veux faire partie d'un gang
genève chanteur
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toi mais tu as sorti apapaatai
j'ai trouvé l'agencé promis j'ai
absolument besoin de leçons de piano
oui j'étais extrêmement mauvais un
moment inoubliable un tournant dans nos
vies je sais que ça va être très très
chaud non il y a
dresse pas la peur tu empêcher de faire
ce que tu aimes vous savez ce qu'il ya
de bien quand on touche le fond c'est
qu'il n'y a qu'une issue possible et
c'est vraiment
tous en scène
le magasin se redresser fortement 15
minutes
à mon âge
oh
keevill
la dame dans l'allée numéro 6 est
franchement trop bien